[MUSIC PLAYING]
WESLEY CHUN: Hey, developers,
and welcome to the G Suite Dev
Show.
I'm your host, Wesley Chun.
Today we're going to
explore how to add
text and shapes to presentations
using the Google Slides API.
As a bonus, we'll also show you
how to add text into shapes.
When you create a
brand-new slide deck,
you get one default title site
which has got two text boxes--
one for a title and
another for a subtitle.
Our sample app will show you
how to use the API to fill
in both text boxes.
The core functionality
of the app,
however, will be
to add a new slide.
We'll use the main point
layout, which, as you can see,
gives us a slide with
one largish text box
but is otherwise empty.
So we can add some
crazy shapes to it.
To complete the demo,
we'll also add text
to not only the text box,
but also to all the shapes.
Our sample app will be
done in Python for brevity.
The client library
can be installed
with a single PIP
command, or PIP 3
if you're a Python 3 user.
If you're not a
Python developer,
just use it as
pseudocode to learn with.
Then build your app
with any language
supported by the Google
API's client libraries.
Check out the link
to get the client
library for your language.
Next, create a
Google API project
in the developers console
with the Slides API enabled,
if you haven't already.
If you want to get a head start
before we look at our sample
app, feel free to review the
Adding Text and Shapes How-To,
but it's optional.
If you're set, let's
go to the computer
and see how to add text and
shapes to slides using the API.
We'll start with
lines 1 through 16.
This is your standard imports
and boilerplate authorization
code, except for line 8
where we define the gen UUID
lambda, which basically
calls into a standard library
function to get randomly-created
UUIDs, or Unique IDs,
as a string.
We're going to use
this down below where
we need unique object IDs.
Line 10 is a read-write
scope for slides.
And line 16 is where we
create the service end
point for the slides API.
Lines 18 to 24 are
where we create
a brand-new presentation, then
grabbing the title and subtitle
text box IDs from
the default title
slide from the API response
that we see from 22 to 24.
Lines 25 to 30 is where
we use the function
that we created on line 8 to
generate random object IDs.
Now why would you generate
your own IDs rather
than getting them from the API?
Because you can use these
IDs for the remaining
requests in a single batch.
If you let the API
do it, you need
to lay a lot more
additional calls--
make a call to create
something, then make
another call to get
the IDs, then make
another call using those IDs.
All these extra calls
chew up your quota.
So it's best to minimize
by rolling your own IDs
and using them.
Note that in this
app, as we will see,
we only have two
API calls total--
one to create the
presentation and another one
to do everything else.
If you don't create your own
IDs, at least for this app,
you'll need at least
five API calls.
Lines 32 to 46 are
the requests to create
a new slide for
our shapes, as well
as filling in most text boxes.
Specifically, 35 to 42 is
where we create the new slide
with a main point
layout, passing
in our generated IDs for both
the slide and that largish text
box we mentioned earlier.
The placeholder
ID mappings field
is an array to provide the
IDs for the elements that
are part of that layout.
We only have one item, because
the main point slide only
has that one largish text box.
43 to 46 is where we add
the title and subtitle
text on that default
title slide and the text
for that largish text box
on the main point slide.
Now 47 down to 94
is a large block
that creates the three shapes.
The code to create each shape
are nearly identical, so let's
chat briefly about
them in general.
When placing or manipulating
shapes or images on slides,
developers must calculate or
otherwise provide the desired
sizes and transforms.
Resizing, rotating,
and similar operations
require some basic
knowledge of matrix math.
Take a look at the Page Elements
page in the documentation,
as well as the Transforms
Concept Guide for more details.
But if you're short
on time, don't
want to deal with the math,
or maybe you're thinking,
I just want to draw a
smiley face on a slide,
one common pattern, then, is
to bring up the Slides user
interface, create a blank
slide, and place your image
or draw your shape the way you
want with the size you want,
and putting it exactly
where you want.
Once you have that,
you can use the API
to do a get call
on the presentation
and grab that critical size and
transform that you need, just
like what you see here, and then
drop them right into your code,
like we did with the
Python equivalent
you see here on 47 to 62.
And likewise for the other
shapes from 63 to 94.
Since we're showing you
how to add text and shapes,
we might as well show you
how to add text into shapes.
So that's what the requests
on 96 to 98 are for.
Notice that the format is
identical as adding text
to the text boxes,
like we did above.
And then finally, on lines
100 to 102, send all 10
of these requests in one
call to batch update.
Then let the user know
everything's done.
Let's double-check that.
One, create slide.
Three, insert text.
1, 2, 3, create shape.
And three more insert text
requests make 10 total.
And that's it.
Well, after you've
executed the script,
confirm that you've got a new
presentation in your Drive
folder that has a slide with the
text and shapes as advertised.
So now you know how to add
text and shapes to slides,
as well as how to
add text into shapes.
If you want to take a closer
look at the Python code,
check out the Deep
Dive blog post.
Now that you know how
to add text and shapes,
perhaps you want to explore
formatting that text.
The first link takes you to
that blog post and video.
Well, what if you have a bunch
of text placeholders in a slide
template so you can generate
custom decks for each
of your clients?
Well, the second link points
you to that post and video.
Finally, if you're brand
new to the Slides API,
check out the overview
introducing you
to the API basics concepts
that you need to know.
If you're writing
applications to generate
slide presentations,
there's a good chance
you'll be adding text.
But on the off-chance
you want to add
shapes or text in shapes, you
now know how to do that, too.
We're excited to share these
features from the Google Slides
API with you and
invite you to check out
more videos in our
library, whether for Slides
or other Google APIs
and developer tools.
Be sure to subscribe
to our channel
to get the latest updates from
all of the Google Developers
teams.
This is Wesley Chun from Google,
and we'll see you upstairs
in the G Suite.
Hey, everyone.
Thanks for watching.
Check out these related videos,
and we'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]